This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
Statements in this program have not been
evaluated by the FDA. As an empowered
individual, you do have options
available. We're honored to continue and
share the teachings of the founding
father of science of ep
Hello everybody and welcome to Daily
with Doc. My name is Becca Dukes and I
am excited to be able to bring to you
this fantastic Friday, pharmacist
Fridays as we are here with pharmacist
Ben Fuches who is a natural
pharmacist. So more than that, just that
you're a nutritional pharmacist.
>> I like that. Yeah, I like that much
better.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, chem chemists hate the word
natural.
No chemist, no chemist would ever say
natural because everything, you know,
natural is kind of weird word because on
the one hand, everything is natural
unless it comes from another galaxy
somewhere. I mean, even then, it's all
off the periodic table. There's 90
elements or 100 elements on the periodic
table and everything's derived from
them. So, everything's natural. But when
you pull the apple off of the tree or
put the berry in the tea or, you know,
make it usable, make the natural stuff
usable, you've processed it. You cooked
it, you picked it, you've cut it, you've
done something to it. So, on the one
hand, everything's natural. On the other
hand, nothing is natural. So, you know,
it's a gibberish word because it doesn't
have really any meaning. But
unfortunately, in our culture, there are
people who get PhDs in gibberish. And
you know what they're called? They're
called marketers.
People Yeah. People who know how words
sound. So when people hear the word
natural in their mind, see if you agree
with this. In their mind, they picture
the herbal essence girl with the
butterflies flying through her head as
she runs as she walks through the the
garden of Eden and the trees and all the
natural, you know, all the kind, gentle
things that nature sort of implies. So
marketers understand how words feel to
people, the implication that words have.
But at the end of the day, cow manure is
natural. You're not going to wash your
face with cow manure. You know, arsenic
and hemlock and uranium. There's all
kinds of things are natural that you're
not going to want to interact with. So
natural is just a meaningless word. But
nutritional pharmacist, now you're
talking, girl, because nutrition,
nutrients are what drugs dream they
could be. When predinisone goes to bed
at night, it dreams it was vitamin C
because nutrients are God's medicine.
And at the end of the day, when you're
sick or have a health challenge, it's
not because you're missing a drug. It's
because you're missing some kind of
nutrient. Even at the point of death,
cells die because they're not being
nutritionally supported. So, nutritional
pharmacist because nutrition is the best
medicine is the way I like to is the way
I like to refer to myself. Well, and and
I would like to just add to it, folks.
Pharmacist Ben Fuches,
he was not Kmart material in the
pharmacy where he started because he was
as a pharmacist recommending nutrition.
And I'm so excited that he did that.
That kind of led him on to another path.
And folks, when we start getting
negative things come back at us, it's
probably because there's some truth in
what we're saying and somebody doesn't
like that because it doesn't meet their
agenda.
Well, welcome to Daily with Doc,
everybody. And that is what we are all
about is sharing truth with you that
you're probably not going to hear
anybody else say or there are a few out
there that are saying that are
continually being censored. And we just
want to make sure that we shout out that
you do not have to have the journey that
you are on that is usually
caused by nutritional deficiency. So, we
are here with nutritional pharmacist and
pharmacist Ben Fuches on Daily with Doc.
And folks, if you were referred to this
program by somebody specific, make sure
that you get back with them. Let them
know that you plugged in and also let
them know what you liked best about the
program today. Now, today's program is
going to be a little bit different as we
are going to be fielding questions. So,
if you're here live with us in the Zoom
daily withdocoom.com,
if you're watching a live stream and
you're not live with us, you can come
join us. And we are here right now. It's
going to be uh Tuesday, Thursdays,
Fridays for sure
from 12 to 100 p.m. Pacific time. So,
we've got Dr. Wlet coming back on with
us Tuesdays and Thursdays. We got
pharmacist Ben on Fridays. and I have
other experts that are going to be
joining us periodically on Mondays and
Wednesdays. So, make sure that you are
connected with us so that you know when
we're going to be live and you can do
that by going to our website
dailywithdoc.com.
Sign up for our email list. And on that
website, you're also going to find some
of our replays, some of our favorite
messages, our good foods, bad foods list
that Dr. Wallik has put together and
also a store and that's presenting the
products that we're talking about on our
program. But again, if you were invited
by somebody specific, make sure that you
get back with them because they may have
their own special way of ordering
products and want to make sure that you
stay connected with the person that
cared enough to share this program with
you. So, pharmacist Ben,
>> we have
>> hundreds of questions and I have I've
shared a few of them with you.
>> So, are you ready to jump into some
questions?
>> Yeah, I I am. Before I before we start,
I want to say something real quickly
here, especially for distributors, also
for guests, but especially for
distributors. You know, we talk about
nutrition on the program and helping
people with their health challenges. And
really, at the end of the day, that's
what Youngevity is all about is is
helping people with health challenges.
But in a bigger picture kind of way, I
don't think we often talk enough about
the fact that we're here to serve
people. We are helping people at the
most fundamental level there is, which
is the level of good health and
nutrition. And I don't I don't think we
talk about that enough. How this is a
service business and we're helping
change lives, change people's lives, not
only with products, but also with
information to help people understand
that there's good news here. The go, you
know, the word gospel means good news.
This is the gospel of nutrition. This is
the good news that you don't have to
suffer with an autoimmune disease
because your mother had it, because it's
in your genes. You don't have to be on
this prescription drug for the rest of
your life because it's there's no known
cause. We have answers. We have
solutions. And people are dying,
literally, not figuratively, literally
dying because they don't have these
solutions. And I want all the
distributors, all all of us as
distributors and and guests as well to
understand that this is our gift to the
world. This is the most beautiful thing
that you could do with your life is to
help people understand how their bodies
work because my people perish for lack
of knowledge. People are dying because
our health care authorities are are the
blind leading the blind. They our
doctors are and this is no knock on
individual doctors but the medical
paradigm the medical model does not
serve us and people are dying number one
and suffering number two. Parents are
suffering because their what's happening
to their kids and what's happening kids
are suffering because of what's
happening to their parents and people
happening to them because they're not
getting the straight scoop. they're not
getting the honest answers and they're
not getting the hope that we can give
people. So I want everybody to
understand as distributors that this is
our gift. This is this is the Lord's
work that we're doing. And this is not
yeah I'm a businessman. I want to make
money. We all need to make money. We all
need to make a living. That will come.
But focus on how we can make a
difference in people's lives. And
Youngevity, the most important thing to
me that Youngevity does is it gives us
an opportunity to make a difference in
the world. It's a platform, a megaphone,
a microphone that we can use to help
spread the word about the power and
importance of a good nutritional
supplement program, of good nutrition,
of good diet, of all the things that we
talk about in longevity. And so that's
that I that we don't talk about that
enough. We get into the nuts and bolts,
but we don't get into the overriding
philosophy. And I think that's really
important and I want to inspire
everybody who's a distributor to go out
and understand that you're doing God's
work by going out and helping people
understand how their bodies work and how
nutritional supplementation, the Inevity
nutritional supplements could be used to
change people's lives.
>> Absolutely. And I'm so glad that you
brought that up because that is
something that I that I share with my
team that I like you said, we don't
share it enough with the community as a
whole and have them realize that our
purpose goes beyond us. It goes beyond
the dollar, but we are here to serve
others.
>> Yeah.
>> And I don't think there's any greater
service than helping somebody find
better
>> reporting in progress.
And that's our pedigree. You know,
that's how Doc started it. And Doc, I
see Doc on the call here. That's how Doc
started it. You know, Doc saw that
people were starving. People were not
sick. They were starving. They were they
were called it sick, but what it really
was, they were missing the key
nutrients, the key mighty 90 essential
nutrients that they need to run their
bodies. And it was started as a mission
to help people to help change people's
lives at the most basic and fundamental
level there is. Then we built a business
around it. But we should never forget
that the core of what we're doing is a
mission to help people to change
people's lives at this basic level. With
that being said, with that being said,
let's let's rock and roll with some of
these questions here.
>> All right, let's go ahead and rock and
roll. And folks, if you are here in the
Zoom with us and you have questions or
if you're out on YouTube, my amazing
team is going to grab those questions
and bring them to our attention. But we
do have a list of questions that have
been emailed that we're going to be
addressing first. If you're here live
with us in the Zoom, use that reactions
button to find the raise hand option as
well and we'll try to work those in. So,
pharmacist Ben, let's start from the
beginning. And Sharon is writing in. She
says, "I recently stopped taking a
pharmaceutical
weekly for seroriatic arthritis and skin
condition for that she's had for three
years. She wants to know what the
half-life chemical of that chemical is
and what's the effects that she should
con um what is the effects and should I
continue um like a folic acid tablet?
>> What what's the pharmaceutical that
you're referring to? It's methtoresate.
>> Oh, okay. Gotcha. Okay. So, uh
methtotrixate
um usually it's given in low doses is
incredibly toxic drug. Uh and it can
take it can take a few days to get out
of your body. Two or three days. I think
the halfife's around 48 hours, something
like that. Um so, usually it's six or
seven half lives to be completely
eliminated out of your body. If the half
life is 48 hours, it's multiply that by
six or so, that'd be a couple of weeks.
Uh it is an incredibly incredibly toxic
drug. It's chemotherapy. It works by
killing things. It's its very nature,
its very mechanism of action is to kill
things. In the case of rheumatoid, it
kills immune cells. It's uses
chemotherapy to kill cancer cells. And
it is one of the most hideous drugs.
There's a lot of h, you know, no drug is
really good for the body. And they're
all toxins in the sense that the body
has to utilize its detoxification
enzymes and detoxification nutrients and
machinery to process that drug. And
sometimes people, you know, I'll say
drugs are toxins. They're literally
toxins to the body. And this is another
distinction between nutrition and drugs.
Nutrients are used by the body. Drugs
are are are cleared out of the body.
nutrients are are integrated into the
structural components and the and the
biochemical metabolic components in
order to run the body. Drugs are
completely foreign and considered the
enemy. Get these Satan behind me. This
is what uh this is what the body says
when it sees methtoresate or any other
prescription drug. And methtoxate
happens to be one of the more hideous
ones. It one of the one of the things it
does is it depletes folic acid. And so
one of the ways you can mitigate some of
the and some of the toxicity associated
with methtrix methtrixate involves
deficiencies in folic acid. So they will
give folic acid with methtoate to
mitigate some of the toxicity uh which
is caused by the the u the folate
deficiencies that methtriate causes.
However, folic acid is an incredibly
important nutrient and uh she should
she's thinking of getting off of folic
acid. That's you want to take folic
acid. The Pyontang Tangerine, by the
way, is a great way to get your folic
acid. Uh, and so I would I wouldn't take
her off of any nutrients that she's
using if she was using them for the
methane. Whereas rheumatoid arthritis,
uh, and we've said this before, but it
really bears repeating. Autoimmune
disease according to the medical model
is the fancy word is idiopathic.
Idiopathic is a fancy way of saying I
don't know what the hell is going on.
Excuse my French. I don't know what the
heck is going on. Right. So, idiopath
autoimmunity is considered to be
idiopathic. That means that we have no
idea what the heck's causing it.
Usually, it's because your mother had
it. I.e., it's genetic. You know, that
whole thing. So, here's
only all you have to do is understand I
call what I call biologic forensics. You
know, forensics is when you see symptoms
or see clues and you spot the the
perpetrator. You find the perpetrator
based on the clues. Well, I like to do
something I call biologic forensics,
which is where you see clues, i.e.
symptoms, bi biological clues or
symptoms, and then you figure things out
by backtracking. It's just forensics. If
you're an engineer, you call
troubleshooting. Same idea. So, what's
an autoimmune disease? The body attacks,
you know, the immune system attacks
parts of the body. So, what's wrong? Why
would the body why would the immune
system attack your thyroid or attack
your joints or attack your pancreas or
you know various parts of the body? Why
would it do that? Oh, because the body's
stupid. That's why. And that's really
the the you know, I'm being facicious,
but that's really the perspective of the
medical model. Your body's just stupid.
It makes it's making a mistake. No, the
body ain't stupid. It ain't making a
mistake. It's got millions of years of
evolution behind it to it's perfectly
refined. So then what is the perfect
reason for it to attack itself? Well,
obviously it sees. We'll take the thy
We'll take the joints. In rheumatoid
arthritis, it's the joints. We'll take
the connective tissue.
>> How about seroriatic arthritis? Is that
the same or similar?
>> Yeah, seroriatic arthritis is a
combination of two autoimmune diseases.
And most people most people will have
multiple autoimmune diseases because
it's the same real mechanism and you'll
understand that when I talk tell you how
it happens. Seroriatic arthritis is
arthritis,
rheumatoid arthritis that affects the
joints. That's an autoimmune disease of
the connective tissue in the joints plus
psoriasis which is an autoimmune disease
where the skin cells get attacked. So
you got skin cells being attacked and
you've got connective tissue cells being
attacked or connected tissue being
attacked. Right? So you got the those
are the two and so they're two different
autoimmune diseases combined in one. You
remember two two bins in one. Same idea
two two diseases in one. So riasis
rheumat and arthritis. Anyway,
autoimmune disease, the joint, the
immune system is attacking. Here's the
part that you want to understand. And
when you understand this, you it'll make
sense to you why it happens. The body or
the immune system is seeing something
wrong, something distorted with the skin
cells or with the the cartilage, the
connective tissue. It's seeing something
distorted. There's a distortion. So then
the question becomes, what causes the
distortion, right? Why is it seeing
distortion? Well, it turns out that when
toxicity gets into the blood, as you
know, we always say all disease is cell
disease.
>> In this case, it's the disease of the
cartilage cells and the and the
cartilage and the connective tissue. And
then uh the keratinosytes, the skin
cells, all disease is cell disease. But
this is important, but listen what I'm
going to say now. All disease is cell
disease. But all cell disease is
preceded by dirty blood.
Dirty blood. The blood is the life of
the body. It's from Leviticus. The blood
is the life of the body. Oxygen is
carried through the blood. Nutrition is
carried through the blood. Toxicity is
removed through the blood. And
electricity is generated through the
movement of blood. Everything is about
the blood. All disease is cell disease
but all cell disease is preceded by
dirty blood. So what is the blood
relationship to autoimmune disease?
Because all diseases are dirty blood.
What happens is the major point of
entrance into the bloodstream. There's a
there's three points but the major point
of entrance into the bloodstream is at
the level of the small intestine.
The small intestine is juxtaposed with
the blood. And it makes sense because
you eat food, you digest in your
stomach, it gets broken down and the
vitamins and the aminos and the fatty
acids go in the the mighty non-
essential nutrients, the minerals, etc.
go into the blood through the intestine.
So the intestine is a portal to the
bloodstream.
But uh you can't have just anything
going into the blood because the blood
is the sacred space. The blood has to be
clean. Well, it has to be pure. What
happens over time as our the impacts of
poor food choices as well as nutritional
deficiencies kick in is changes in the
uh bacterial population in the intestine
occur.
This is a condition called disbiosis.
Dys means dysfunctional, messed up and
biosis is bacteria. So you have messed
up bacteria. the the small intestine is
in the center of your body. The large
intestine is around it. And most of the
bacteria, you've all heard of the
microbiome, the bacteria that most of
those live in the large intestine. The
small intestine has some bacteria
usually, but not a lot. Why? Because the
small intestine is basically a
nutritional broth for bacteria. There's
all kinds of nutrients in the small
intestine. So, if you have bacteria in
the small intestine, they can
proliferate. They can overgrow. This is
a condition called SIBO, SIBO, and it's
caused by ingestion of the wrong foods,
nutritional deficiencies. Uh, ingestion
of things that kill bacteria or that
change the bacteria. Chlorine is a big
problem. Antibiotics are another
problem. We do things in our culture
that change the bacterial millu of the
intestine and result in proliferation of
bacteria at the level of the small
intestine. And you can rest assured
cancer, heart disease, skin problems,
neurological issues, all of them,
autoimmunity, all have this SIBO at the
core. But what is the mechanism? When
when these bacteria overgrow in the
small intestine, they start secretreting
things that cause inflammation,
inflammatory reactions at the level of
the intestinal wall, which is where the
blood is connected. That's called leaky
gut syndrome, which you all heard
probably of. Leaky gut syndrome is
secondary to or follows SIBO, small
intestinal bacterial overgrowth. Once
that bacterial wall of the that
intestinal wall expands,
things enter into the bloodstream. Now
that intestinal expan intestinal wall
expansion, that leaky gut is compounded
by things like gluten and lectins in
foods and and eating the wrong kinds of
foods and nutritional deficiencies. All
of these compound to create uh to create
this leaky gut issue. Toxicity enters
into the bloodstream. All disease has
this in common. All of it. Parkinson's
disease, movement disorders, Alzheimer's
issues, cancer, heart disease, skin
problems, all of it has this mechanism
behind it. But with autoimmunity,
what happens is these toxins enter into
the bloodstream and the body will
protect itself from these toxins by
surrounding the toxin in the bloodstream
with immune cells, basically pus. You
can think of pus. Okay, it's that's a
little graphic, but and it's not exactly
right, but basically that's that that's
a good way of imagining it. You have now
toxins in the bloodstream that coming
from bacteria and bacterial toxins and
food particles and all kinds of stuff
that has gotten into the intestine and
and snuck into the bloodstream through
the leaky gut. Now you have these
circulating
immune complexes. They call them CIC's
and doctors will check for them and and
people who have rheumatoid will have
their CIC's checked. This is this is not
I'm not making this up. This is not
something that nobody knows about.
Everybody knows about CIC's. So these
CICs float around in the bloodstream and
that's the way the body protects itself.
And then ultimately the body does
something very logical because the body
is very logical that I used to do when I
was a kid.
When I was a kid I had a messy room. I
used to be I was known for having a
horribly messy bedroom. And my mom would
come in and you guys can all relate to
this. Clean your room up, young man. And
I hit upon a strategy for cleaning my
room in two minutes flat. No matter how
messy my room was, I knew exactly how to
clean my room. And in two minutes, my
mom would come back and, "Oh my god,
what did you do?" Well, of course, I did
what any any clever American child would
do when their room was messy and they
had to clean it all up. I shoved
everything under the bed, right? And so
my room was clean. Well, the body is
just as smart. And instead of taking
these CIC's and and letting these CICs
float around the blood, it will shove
them under the bed. Except to the body,
under the bed is the soft tissues of the
organs and the various cells and the
connective tissue. And so when over the
course of time as these CICs accumulate
the body will start shoving the CIC's in
the thyroid and in the pancreas and the
in the connective tissue and in the
various parts of the body that to get it
out of the blood. It just shoves it
under the bed. Well, now you have the
thyroid with all of these immune cells
and immune complexes integrated into
them or the connective tissue. So the
body sees that correctly as an enemy and
it will initiate an immune attack
against these molecules. It's called
molecular mimicry and these molecules
will be attacked in the thyroid. So this
is the mechanism and it's a very
fascinating mechanism but you don't need
to know it. This is so if anybody ever
questions it and says oh my doctor told
me my mother had it so I have it. Now
you can tell them the mechanism but you
don't need to know it because if you
simply change the way you eat and start
working with digestive support your uh
your autoimmune systems will go away.
And people have autoimmunity, multiple
sclerosis or rheumatoid arthritis or
lupus or whatever it is, shogrin
syndrome, whatever it is, will notice
that their symptoms get worse and flare
up. And they'll notice if they pay
attention and do a food diary, they're
flaring up when they're eating certain
foods.
>> They'll also notice that if they stop
eating, their symptoms will subside.
and not occasionally all the time. In
fact, Dr. Terry Walls, who was a medical
doctor, she wrote a book about it. She
had multiple sclerosis, which is one of
the most horrific, if not the most
horrific, of all the autoimmune
diseases. She had it and she cured
herself. Yes, I use the cure word
because she wrote it. She wrote it in
her book. It's called the Walls
Protocol. And she did it by laying off
gluten and by changing the way she ate
and by intermittent fasting and doing
all the things I'm talking about. So I
gave you the mechanism. So now you know
there's a mechanism. I always give you
mechanisms because I always want you to
know there's a mechanism behind these
things. But you don't need to know it.
You do a food diary. You write down all
the foods you're going to find that
you're flaring up when you when you're
eating gluten or when you're eating
lectins. And by the way, there's all
kinds of things in foods that we think
are okay foods uh that are problematic
because they change SIBO. They they feed
the bacteria. Eggplant, broccoli,
avocados. These are all foods that we
think. Pears, apples, bananas. These are
all foods that we think of as good
foods. Oh, I only eat organic. Oh, I
only eat vegan. I only eat vegetarian.
You could be eating avocados and you
could be sparking off these kinds of
reactions. So, you got to do a food
diary. You got to write everything down
and then you have to uh see how you feel
based on the food. Seriatic arthritis is
very good because the skin the skin uh
is the fastest moving tissue in the body
next to the intestine and you'll see
results quickly. You'll notice things on
the skin very quickly. So the skin is a
great window to the inner inner
metabolism to what's happening inside
the body. So the when you have psoriasis
or a skin issue, breaking out,
sensitive, oh sensitive skin is another
common issue associated with SIBO. All
skin issues are associated with SIBO,
but sensitive skin is another good
barometer. And then the second then, so
you do the food diary and you eliminate
problem foods, but then you got to start
working on the digestive system. One of
the coolest things about Youngevity
products, there's a lot of really cool
products and Doc and Richard Ren and the
formulators just did an incredible job
and everybody's distributing Youngevity
formulations should be proud and that
they have this incredible selection of
nutritional supplements to choose from
to handle people's health challenges and
even if they don't have health
challenges just to be nutritionally to
keep their nutritionally whole. So, uh,
the second thing is use digestive
support nutrients. And Youngevity has
got a wide range of wonderful digestive
support supplements. And let me give a
shout out to Dr. Joanne Conway at this
point because she is a digestive system
guru. She's written books on the
digestive system and she knows it inside
and out. So, uh, she's formulated a
wonderful product called the ultimate
microbiome. There's the daily digest.
There's Dr. Ariza's liver cleanse. And
the liver is part of the digestive
system as is the gallbladder. Um, of
course there's the nightly essence. One
of my favorite all-time favorite
longevity products that doesn't get
anywhere near the love it it deserves in
my opinion. Perfect for people who deal
with autoimmune diseases for this gal on
seriatic arthritis is the I26.
Super underappreciated.
It's genius. It's a genius supplement.
And and let me just I know we talked
about it before. Let me just say it
again. It is the the science behind it
is brilliant. So, we talked about these
bacteria overgrowing in the in the
intestine responsible for leaky gut and
then and then dirty blood and then all
health challenges. So, I26
is a special powder. It's an egg powder
that comes from eggs
that were laid by chickens
that were given a special kind of
antigen to stimulate their immune
system. They give the chickens this
antigen.
Antigens stimulate the immune system.
The immune system of the chicken is now
stimulated. So it makes these powerful
antibodies,
natural antibiotics
uh and then these powerful antibodies,
natural antibiotics come out in the eggs
and they powder the eggs up. They dry
the eggs up. They make them powder and
they sell it. And this stuff is like a
miracle for SIBO. And it works because
it kills the bacteria, the SIBO, the the
hyperp proliferating bacteria in the
intestine. And it tastes has a little
benign taste, but does it I like the
taste. I put it in my smoothie. I don't
have an autoimmune disease. I do it
anyway. It's good for everybody to do,
but it's especially good for people with
seriatic arthritis or autoimmune
diseases or anything, any health
challenges because they're all related
to SIBO and it works to kill those
excess bacteria.
Don't underestimate the power and the
importance of the I26. Yes, I'm sorry.
>> Okay. So, with that being said, I have
somebody that has a reoccurring H pylori
and they're wanting to know what they
can do
>> Okay. So, H pylori is another thing. So,
let's talk you want to talk about H.
Pylori or is that
>> let's Yeah, let's talk about H. Pylori
real quick.
>> So, H pylori fascinating fascinating
story about H. Pylori. So, back when I
graduated pharmacy school, back in the
old days, I'm almost embarrassed to tell
you, I'm pretty old,
uh, you know, 1986, I graduated pharmacy
school. The number one best-selling
medicine, which we would fill a hundred
plus scripts a day for, was Tagamett.
And then also another one called Zantac.
Now, you've probably heard of Tagamet
and Zantac these days because now you
can get over the counter. Uh, but
everybody was on Tagamet and Zantac.
Number one, number two drugs every year.
Zantac and Tagamett. So what is Zantac
and Tagamett? Zantac and Tagamat are
drugs that suppress acid. And the reason
everybody was taking Tagamet and Zantac
is because people had stomach ulcers.
And back then everybody said stomach
ulcers were caused by too much acid. So
you just take Tagam, you take Zantac.
Well, there were these two scientists in
Australia. I forgot their names. and
they were out there saying, "Wait a
minute. I don't think it's the acid." It
turns out that that people have stomach
ulcers also have uh this bacteria. They
also have a bacteria called H. pylori in
their stomach. And they try to they
tried to tell everybody and nobody would
listen to them because everybody knew,
you know, everybody when everybody knows
something, you gota you got to be a
little bit careful when everybody knows
something and everybody knew that it was
acid that caused ulcers. these two crazy
doctors in Australia, they said, "Oh no,
it's this bacteria. It's this H pylori
that's causing the problem." They
actually, they were so frustrated to try
to get this news out. Nobody's
listening. They actually got a big old
cup filled with H pylori
and they drank it. They drank the H
pylori just for science in the name of
science to prove uh to prove that it was
the H pylori. Sure enough, they drank
the H. pylori. They were perfectly
healthy. Next thing they know, they had
stomach ulcers. And finally, the news
got out that it was the H. pylori, not
the tag. But the great irony of this
whole thing is is H. pylori thrives
under conditions of low stomach acid.
So, it wasn't the too much stomach acid
that was causing the ulcers. It's too
little stomach acid that was causing the
ulcers. Today, now if you have an ulcer,
they don't use tagamin anymore or
Zantac. What do they give you for an
ulcer? They give you an antibiotic
to kill H. pylori because now everybody
knows it's H. pylori, not too much
stomach acid. Now, taking a drug that
suppresses acid or having too little
stomach acid is a big problem. Nexium,
pryloac, tagamet, zantac. These are big
problems. Deficiencies in stomach acid
are also big problems. Why? Number one,
we talked about H. pylori. H. pylori can
thrive. But even worse,
under conditions of low stomach acid,
bacteria in the intestine proliferate.
And one of the main causes of SIBO is
low stomach acid.
So if you have SIBO, one of the things
you probably also have is a chlorohria
or low stomach acid. And because when
you have low stomach acid
and excess bacteria,
the val the sphincter that connects the
esophagus to the stomach becomes loose
and flabby.
Acid is supposed to tighten the
sphincter. Why? Because when you have
acid in your stomach, you don't want the
acid to splash back up. But under
conditions of low stomach acid, the
sphincter becomes loose and then this
little stomach acid that you have can
splash back up. And if you have SIBO,
the gases that are produced by the
bacteria can force the acid up. So
heartburn and gastroosophageal reflux
disease is one of the and SIBO are the
some of the things that can happen when
you have low stomach acid. So for H
pylori, what you want to do is number
one, acidify
the contents of the stomach. One of the
all-time great longevity products in my
humble opinion.
And we pharmacists, we love
multifunctionality.
That's what I'm always looking for. One
of the reasons I love nutritional
supplementation in general is because
it's multifunctional.
So you take, you know, you take your
Beyond Tangy Tangerine because you want
to help your immune system and you get
better skin and you get better bones.
You take your ultimate EFAs because you
want to have a softer skin and you have
better menstrual cycles or you have uh
your female health issues go away. Then
these nutritional supplementations
multifunctional. With drugs, you get you
get a a biochemical effect, not a not a
benefit, but a biochemical effect and
then you get side effects. With
nutrition, you get a benefit and then
you get side benefits. So, one of my
favorite multifunctional longevity
supplements and and it's one of the
least expensive longevity supplements,
multifunctional, incredibly valuable is
the ultimate enzymes.
This thing is amazing. Number one, it's
obviously digestive enzymes. So, it's
going to help you with your digestion.
But did you know ultimate enzymes on an
empty stomach are anti-inflammatory?
They'll help you with arthritis pain or
back pain or dental pain for that
matter. The ultimate enzymes taken on an
empty stomach will accelerate the
healing of bruising and postsurgical
trauma. So if you're going to go into
surgery or if you're going to have
plastic surgery, take your ultimate
enzymes a couple weeks before and a
couple weeks after on an empty stomach
and they'll support healing. They'll
speed the healing process up. We talked
about dirty blood and blood thickening.
And by the way, one of the one of the
most notorious effects of the jab, you
guys know what I'm talking about, is
clotting of the blood and thickening of
the blood, which anybody who understands
how the body works could have predicted.
The altered enzymes are a natural blood
thinner. They can help uh improve the
prognosis of people who have thrombosis
or or blood clots or just plain old
dirty blood. But of course, they're also
amazing for the digestive system. And
one of the reasons they're so amazing
for the digestive system in addition to
the fact that they contain uh digestive
enzymes, the ultimate enzymes contain
digestive enzymes is they contain
another molecule that in itself is
fabulously multifunctional and it's a
little tiny. You know, if you look at
the supplement facts, you might not even
notice it. It's called betane HCL.
Betane hydrochloro, right? So betane HCL
is made up of two two components betane
and HCL. The HCL is hydrochloric acid.
It acidifies the contents of the stomach
for people who are dealing with H.
pylori or people are dealing with low
stomach acid or people have SIBO
secondary to low stomach acid. But in
addition to the HCL, the betane is also
super valuable. The betane is a
methylating agent. So for people who are
worried about methylation issues, you
know, everybody's talking about MTHFR
and methylation problems, betane is a
methylating agent. Betane is also a
source of one of nature's most important
detoxifiers
and anti-aging connective tissue
builders for the for the skin and for
the joints and for the heart, for the
blood vessels and for the fascia. And
that's called and for detoxification.
And that's a molecule called glycine.
Betane is technically trimethyl glycine.
So it's got methyl, it's got glycine,
and it's got HCL. And it's all in the
ultimate enzymes, which are inexpensive
and not only important for digestion,
but important for for detox, for blood
thinning, for for uh anti-inflammatory
issues, and for the healing healing of
traumas and bruises and wounds and such.
And that's all in the ultimate enzymes.
So she should be on the ultimate
enzymes. I personally like people to
take a little non juice. I know we don't
have the non juice anymore. I'm I'm so I
was sorry to find out. Uh but I used to
tell people take a little bit of noni
juice, but the that'll help the
digestive enzymes work as well. So
acidification is the main strategy for H
pylori issues. I26 might help also. By
the way, H pylori is al is naturally
found in the body. It's just not
naturally found in the stomach.
>> All right. Wow. Okay, folks. I hope you
took notes. And if you didn't take
notes, that's okay because you can find
the replays for this program on our
YouTube channel. Just go to Critical
Health News channel. On YouTube, on
Rumble, also Critical Health News. On
Facebook, it's Critical Health. We have
all of these replays of our programming
on those platforms and many, many more.
So, if you're on Patreon, if you're on
Spotify, if you're on Amazon Music, if
you are listening to even iHeart, I've
got my cheat list over here. Uh, Simple
Cast, Castbox, Radio Public, Riverside
FM, Rumble. Hello, Rumble. And even
KSCO, we have Dave Michaels on with us
today.
>> Oh, Dave Michaels is on. Hey, Dave.
>> Yes. So Dave, he he keeps our program
active on KSO and KOMY. So I want to do
a shout out to both of those listening
groups and around the world. And the way
that you can help us get this message
around the world everybody is to share
this program with your friends, with
your family. If you are a podcaster, a
broadcaster, and you would like to get
involved with us, this is your call to
action to reach out to us on
dailywithdoc.com.
Use that contact option and send myself
an email and we will make sure that we
get you connected with us that you also
can be part of this crusade to help save
the world and reduce
sickness. Right, babe.
>> Absolutely. Make the world a better
place.
>> Yes, we want to make the world a better
place. Well, the questions are just
coming in nonstop here. I I can see them
on YouTube. I can see them here in the
Zoom room. We've got them on Rumble
coming in. And I have some of my
co-hosts with their hands raised
bringing those questions to the room.
So, let's go ahead and get some of these
questions also answered. So, let's first
go to AJ. AJ, go ahead and unmute
yourself. And what questions are you
bringing to Pharmacist Ben today?
>> Hey, Ben. Uh, Becca, doc, how are you?
>> Good to see you, AJ.
>> Good to see you, Ben. It's always
exciting having you on. I'm gonna try
and make this brief because, as Becca
mentioned, there quite a number of
questions. I got a call from a woman
named Betty who has MS
and she's dealing with um potentially
having a hip surgery because she's has
bone on bone stuff going on and she is
wondering what she can take uh pre or
postsurgery. She's kind of convinced
that she wants to have the surgery and
what can she possibly do. All right. So,
let's talk about let's talk about all
all that subject. Before we get into
that, I want to I want to just briefly
mention a subject called simplexity.
Simplex simplexity is a physics concept
that addresses the
complex nature, the complex forms that
can be built up from the simplest
building blocks. That's the term
simplexity. Simple complex. the simplest
building blocks can lead to the most
complex forms. They can plug in an
equation into a computer and the
computer will spin those that simple
little equation around and create these
massive uh complex topographies, maps
and geographies and geologies that'll
look like landscapes just from one
equation with a couple of numbers. And
in biology and health, the same thing is
true. The simplest concepts can lead to
the most complex forms.
And that's why you hear me repeating
myself over and over and over again. And
I'm sure Doc understands it too because
he's repeating himself over and over and
over again because the simplest ideas
lead to the most complex forms. This is
simplexity. It's a physics concept. So,
this gal has MS and um and uh bone on
bone arthritis, I don't know,
osteoporosis, I'm not sure what the
exact diagnosis was, and she wants to
have a hip replacement. Well, the
simplest forms in terms of biology that
lead to the most comp or the simplest uh
inputs that lead to the most complex
outputs are the digestive system, leaky
gut,
dirty blood, all the things with
nutritional deficiencies, all these
basic ideas. So, MS is an autoimmune
disease. I'm not going to go over the
whole thing again, but you see you see
the mechanism. Autoimmune disease is
stuff getting into the blood. you stop
you stop the entrance of toxicity of the
blood, the immune reaction subsides. So
right away she should be doing that. Now
if she's she I imagine this is an older
woman. Does she say how how old she is?
She probably in her 60s I imagine.
>> Yep. Thereabouts.
>> Okay. So she's been having she's had MS
probably for 20 years or so at least 25
years. She's probably had this the the
the beginnings of MS her whole life or
at least in teenagerhood or childhood.
So
over time as you have this digestive
this intestinal issue, SIBO, leaky gut,
you're not going to absorb your
nutrients. You're going to become
starved, malnourished, you're going to
be suffering from malnutrition. So of
course the body is going to begin to
deteriorate. Thus the hip replacement,
thus the bone on bone. And she only said
those two things. I'm sure there's other
things, too. If you start asking her,
there's got to be a list of things. So
first of all, all disease is cell
disease. All cell disease is preceded by
dirty blood. The dirty blood begins at
the gut. I am guaranteeing you 100%. Not
because I'm psychic Ben. I'm pharmacist
Ben. I'm guaranteeing you this woman has
had longstanding digestive health
problems for decades. Okay. Is she on
the call or is this is this somebody?
>> She's on YouTube at this point.
>> Okay. Not send a note back, ma'am, and
tell me and and so you can so everybody
can understand. She's had long-standing
digestive health challenges. So, you
work on the digestive system first.
Everything we just talked about, daily
digest, ultimate microbiome, ultimate
enzymes, um nightly essence, liver cl uh
Dr. Ariza's true to- life liver cleanse.
There's a zillion of them. I'm happy to
go over them with you, but focus on
digestive health. Do a food diary. um uh
eliminate problem foods and and the
problem foods are your problem foods,
not from the internet what your
particular problem foods are. And then
you got to start, this is a woman who's
starving. Literally, she's starving. So,
you got to start putting nutrients back
into the system. Now, I'm not going to
tell her about the macronutrients. We're
going to talk about the micronutrients
here. There is a distinction between the
two. From a micronutrient perspective,
get on the healthy bone and joint pack.
Stat in pharmacy, we say stat. That
means now, today, right away. Stat.
Healthy bone and joint pack. I would
throw in the collagen peptides. Um, and
then also, uh, let me think if there's
anything else. I probably wasn't.
>> Well, I think that's part of the healthy
joint healthy healthy bone and joint
pack, I'm pretty sure. So, yeah, MSM is
also very important. Sul MSM is is
ridiculously valuable for a lot of
things. But yes, MSM collagen peptides
um uh uh the Fitshake whey protein is
very very helpful for building tissue
especially especially uh building
connected tissue and also the Fitshake
protein is also very important for
digestive health as well. So, I would
throw in the fit shake and then I'm I'm
probably missing something, but all the
digestive support, the healthy bone and
joint pack, uh, and then also the fit
shake. I would do those as well. And
then all the digestive digestive health
strategy, things like food diary and pro
eliminating problem foods, etc. She
might also want to throw the I26 in uh
to correct SIBO issues.
>> You demand, Ben. I I I do have other
questions, but maybe Phyllis will take
care of those. Thank you.
>> Thank you, Ben.
>> And by the way, I should tell you this.
I know you probably I know you probably
know this, but before Doc was the
mineral doctor, he was the connective
tissue doctor. And that's what got my
attention. My attention it was the pig
was the pig pack. That that when I first
heard him talk about the pig pack on on
the tape, my my little pharmacist ears
went pointing up right quickly because
that's how I got into Doc. That's what
really I said this guy is amazing. He
knows what he's talking about. So
anyway, building that connective tissue.
>> Thank you, Ben.
>> Yes.
>> Yes. And the pig pack is where I started
as well. So, um, very much like the
pigpack. And Dave out on YouTube wants
to know how does Ben keep all this
information in his brain? And
>> you know, that's a good question. Let me
let me let me tell you that. Let me tell
you. Biology, biochemistry is a language
and if you speak it, you speak it. It's
like how do you speak English? Look at
all the words you know when you speak
English. You don't have to think about
it. You just the words come out. They
flow out of you. Biology is like that.
You have to speak biology. You have to
speak chemistry. And when you speak it,
you're fluent in it. It all just
perfectly makes sense. Like syntax like
like verbs and nouns go together and
predicates and and pronouns, they all go
together. They flow together. That's how
biology is and that's how biochemistry
is. That's why if you're sick, you don't
want to go to a doctor. You want to go
to a biochemist or a somebody who
understands how the chemical reactions
work, the pathways, how everything
flows. So, I don't have to keep it in my
head because it's a syntax. It's a
language. And if you understand the
rules of grammar, you can understand how
to make sentences. And if you understand
the rules of chemistry, you can
understand how everything is put
together and how to work symptoms. And
so, that's that that's it's I'm not that
smart. I'm really not that smart. I just
know things like I know a language. I'm
fluent.
>> All right. Well, I'm gonna disagree with
you as far as smartness goes, but that's
all right.
>> All right.
>> Let's go to Phyllis before he gets
before he gets to rebuttle that. And if
can you take your plugs out for just a
minute, Ben? I need to Yeah, take your
ear things out for just a minute. Folks,
this program is not meant to take the
place of your primary care physician,
nor is it to
>> I heard that
>> treat or prevent any disease. But folks,
the FDA requires us to let you know that
what I just said. Um, and pharmacist
been, you know, he has he has his
thoughts on that as well. But folks,
when you give the body what it needs,
the body itself can do some amazing
amazing things.
>> Yeah. We don't have to cure, you know,
they don't, the government and FDA and
the regulatory agencies, they don't want
you saying you're going to cure this and
you're going to cure that. We don't have
to talk about that. We're just going to
help you feel better. They can't they
don't own feeling better. You know,
diseases are brand names. I can't say
Kleenex. I can say tissues. Diabetes is
a brand name. The doctors own the brand
names. That's their copyright. Fine. Let
them have it. I got dislycemia. I got
messed up blood sugar. You can have your
diabetes. I can take care of your
dislycemia. I'm not going to cure
anything because cure is magic. We're
reversing. This is science. In science,
you reverse. The body is going this way.
You take it this way. The body can turn
on a dime. But we got to turn on a dime
first. And by the way, the sicker you
are, the faster you turn it around. This
should be the best news anybody ever
hears. The the worse your symptoms are,
the faster they'll start to go away.
Now, it may take longer for them to
completely go away, but the beginnings
will happen faster the sicker you are.
The more pounds you need to lose, the
faster the pounds come off. It's the
last few pounds that are the hardest.
The first pounds come off the quickest.
The more nutritionally deficient you
are, the faster your body absorbs them.
Like a dry sponge sucks up more water
than a wet sponge. So, you know, people
who supplement all the time, they're not
going to notice a Beyond Tangy
Tangerine. But your neighbors, and still
90% of people aren't supplementing,
they're going to notice it quickly. And
that's the great gift that God gave us.
That's the great gift of the human body
is the sicker we are, the faster we turn
it around, the more nutritionally
deficient we are, the faster we absorb
those nutrients. And I want everybody to
understand, we're not here to cure
anything. We're here to help people feel
better, to reverse their health
challenges, to give people hope. And you
don't need to have a medical credential
to give people hope and to help them
feel better.
>> That's right. Amen. All right, Phyllis,
go ahead. What questions do you have
today?
>> Well, hello, Ben. And AJ's right. It's
always exciting when you're on. Love it.
Simplexity always turn into something.
Um, so I'll run through a few quick
ones. Um, Olga on YouTube wants to know,
is glucco gel best taken on an empty
stomach or with a meal?
>> Uh, I would personally say with a meal
because you want some digestive juices
going in order to get maximum absorption
of the gluccog caps. And by the way,
since you brought the glucco gel caps
up, um, we're talking about
multifunctionality, and the gluccoel
caps are obviously marketed for for
joints and for arthritis, but you have
a major part of the Let me just digress
real quick. The body is made up of four
kinds of stuff. Okay? In biology, we
don't say stuff. That's a that's a
colloquial word. In biology, we say
tissues. Okay? So, the body's made up of
four kinds of stuff, i.e. tissues. And
if you've ever been to the bodies
exhibit, have you ever seen the bodies
exhibit at the museum?
>> You look at the body's exhibit, people
haven't seen it, you see the body
without the skin. I call that the flesh
robot.
>> And the flesh robot is the part of our
body that does all the work. And then
it's covered with a special kind of
covering called epithelial tissue. And
then the whole thing is electrified with
nervous tissue. So you got the flesh
robot, which is the bulk of the body.
And if you go to the body museum, you
can see that's a body. It doesn't look
like an Indian or an Asian or an
African-American or, you know, a white
person or an Eskimo. It just looks like
a what we all look like inside. We're
all flesh robots inside.
That's the part of the body that
deteriorates the most when we get older.
In fact, all the things we hate about
aging is the result of the deterioration
of the flesh robot. The flesh robot is
made up of two kinds of tissues, two
kinds of stuff called muscle tissue and
connective tissue. And the most
important part of the body, the part of
the body that pulls everything together
and that feeds all of the cells is the
connective tissue. The blood, by the
way, is liquid connective tissue. The
blood vessels are connective tissue. The
heart sits on a scaffolding of
connective tissue. The bones are
connective tissue. The joints are
connective tissue. All of the organs
inside the body are wrapped around in a
spiderweb of connective tissue called
fascia. The skin underneath the surface
is connective tissue. All of the things
we hate about aging, the wrinkles, the
fine lines, the osteoporosis, the joint
pain, the joint deterioration, the heart
disease, the heart problems, the
vascular health issues, the prolapses,
the ruptures, the hernas, everything we
hate about aging is the result of the
deterioration of the connective tissue.
A long time ago, not 300 years ago,
there was a horrible disease. Actually,
throughout all history, there was a
horrible disease up until about 300
years ago that was the result of
connective tissue deterioration.
It was a horrible disease. People's
teeth would fall out of their out of
their mouths. Their their bones would
turn to mush. Their blood vessels would
explode and they would hemorrhage to
death. They would have these horrible
bruises and and wounds on their skin
that wouldn't heal. And this is the
disease. It was a horrible disease. It
was one of the leading cause of death
and it would cause great pain before
people died. Of course, this disease was
was cured. It was it was not cured. But
they figured out how to prevent the
disease and cure the disease actually in
the 1700 in the 1700s I believe or late
1600s by giving a little bit of oranges,
giving a little bit of lime. Correct.
The disease was called scurvy. Right.
And uh the Brit sailors used to suffer
from this disease because they would eat
they would eat uh ham biscuits and
smoked meats and they didn't know
anything about nutrition back then. So
they they would subsist on foods that
didn't have a lot of vitamin C in them.
But this one British doctor noticed that
when they went off to Madagascar and got
off on got off the boat and got off the
island started eating limes and citrus
fruits from the island, boom, their
scurvy would go away. So he started to
do a little studying and he he said,
"Oh, there's something in this lime here
in this citrus that cures scurvy." And
he started giving it to all the British
sailors and the French didn't know about
it and the Portuguese didn't know about
it and the Dutch didn't know about it
and the Spanish didn't know about it. So
the British became this great empire
because sometimes 90% of sailors would
die of scurvy. It was a horrible
disease. It was keeping people from
being from going in the ocean from from
having naval empires. But the British
figured out they became a great naval
empire because of it. Actually,
ironically, the Chinese knew about it
before even the British knew about it,
and they were giving their sailor
sprouts. That's a whole another story.
Sprouts are are very good source of
vitamin C. Well, it wasn't until the
early 1900s, they they knew that there
was something in citrus that was curing
the scurvy, but it wasn't until the
early 1900s that probably the greatest
my hero, my personal biochemical hero
and just the greatest biochemist ever
lived, a guy named Albert St. Georgie,
he was doing he was doing uh uh some
research. He wanted to figure out what
the heck is going on in these limes and
in this lemons and citrus fruit. And he
found an acidic little piece of acid
that was in the oranges. And this little
piece of acid seemed to have been doing
the work. It was curing the scurvy. So
he took this acid and he called it
without scurvy acid because it helped
cure scurvy. In biology or in chemistry
or in English even the letter A means
without. And in Latin scurvy or the
derivative word of scurvy is scorbic. He
called this acid ascorbic acid. And
ascorbic acid was the without scurvy
acid. It was the miracle that was curing
connective tissue. Well, luckily today
we don't have scurvy because we got we
all get a little bit of uh we all get a
little bit of vitamin C. You know, we
get our our vitamin C's from the RDAs.
What do the RDA stand for?
>> Ridiculously deficient on a lotments.
ridiculous deficiency allowance, right?
Because while we get enough vitamin C to
so we don't get scurvy,
we don't get enough vitamin C so we can
be maximally healthy. So we can have
great connective tissue. Who cares about
scurvy? We want to have great connective
tissue. And today we don't have scurvy
anymore, but we have something else. We
have subclinical
scurvy. What does subclinical mean? It's
not bad enough to put you in the clinic,
to put you in the hospital, but it's
subclinical. It's still scurvy, but it's
just not bad enough. You know what the
other name for subclinical scurvy has a
synonym? The sub other name for
subclinical scurvy is
aging.
Aging is subclinical scurvy.
Aging. All the things we had about a
about uh about aging, the the bone
problems and the joint problems and the
gum problems and the heart problems are
all scurvy. We're subclinical scurvy. So
what do you do? You have to make sure
that you're using your mighty 90
essential nutrients especially the
beyond tangy tangerine which if it has
features nothing else it features super
high doses of this incredibly important
ascorbic acid vitamin. Now you ask me
about gluccogel caps. The glucco gel
caps provide the raw material
for building the connective tissue. And
the combination of your beyond tangy
tangerine and your glucco gel caps are
not only important for the joints which
we market you know gluccoel caps market
for arthritis but for preventing
ruptures and preventing hernas and
protecting your your heart and keeping
your heart functioning strong. By the
way, arhythmias can be caused by defects
in the connective tissue, the heart
connective tissue. So for heart disease,
for vascular disease, for uh for skin
disease, for wrinkles, for fine lines,
ladies, I know men too, but ladies
especially, the glucco gel caps should
be they should put a new label on them
that says anti-rinkle caps and
anti-aging caps because they're building
the most important part of the body, the
part of the body that deteriorates the
most significantly as we age. Gluccoel
caps are not just for arthritis. They're
for aging. They're for ruptures and
hernas and heart disease and
osteoporosis. And for you ladies who are
obsessed with taking estrogen and
hormone replacement therapy for your
bones, vit vitamin C is the bone
vitamin. It's builds the it builds the
bones. Way more important than estrogen
with no toxicity. It's certainly fosmax
or bonva or the you know the
prescription drugs they give you for
osteoporosis. So, glucco gel caps for
the bones, for the blood, for the heart,
for the skin, and of course for the
joints if you have arthritis. And then
take it with food. And take it with your
Beyond Tang Tangerine. Wash your glucco
gel caps down with your BTT.
>> Definitely going to take more of those
glucco gel caps.
>> Heck yes. And and completely non-toxic
on top everything else. You can take the
whole bottle. Completely non-toxic. It's
food.
Becca, I assume there's no more time for
questions. Um,
>> no, he's on a roll. So, if he has time
to roll,
>> uh, you know, we save him for next time.
Save them for next.
>> Okay. So, I have I do have one that I
want to fit in because you're talking
about asorbic acid and how does that
relate with citric acid? And if somebody
is allergic to citric acid,
>> nobody's allergic to Hang on. Nobody's
allergic to citric acid. That does not
happen. However, there are certain
components in oranges, which we didn't
we talked about last time, and citrus
fruits in general that can trigger SIBO
like reactions, particularly a molecule
called histamine.
Okay, citrus fruits contain histamine.
You've all heard of antihistamines,
right? So, antihistamines help you when
you have cold, when you have a hay
fever, you take an antihistamine, right?
Because it blocks histamine. Histamine
is a very powerful chemical that's made
by your body
that is made by bacterial cells in the
intestine, especially when you have
SIBO, and also found in foods like
citrus, like se like shellfish
and seafood,
like avocados. These are all foods that
contain histamine. So if you eat oranges
and break out or have sensitivity, it's
likely the histamine. It's likely a
histamine reaction. And so you want to
make sure that you're taking care of the
SIBO, addressing the SIBO. Nobody,
zero people are allergic to cit have a
reaction to citric acid. is a very
benign tiny little chemical structure
that is basically
it's similar to we'll say in fact I
should say similar it is
listen to what I'm going to say for this
person who's allergic to citric acid
says thinks they're allergic to citric
acid every cell in your body you have a
100red trillion cells in the body every
cell in the body every living cell every
bacterial cell every fungal cell every
cell derives its energy
from citric acid via something called
the citric acid cycle.
Okay, you may have heard of the KB
cycle. That's the other name for it.
That this is how we make ATP energy in
the in this I don't want to get into too
much biochemistry, but we'll just say
citric acid is the beginning point of
the biochemical machinery that produces
ATP or energy. So, it's ludicrous. It
doesn't even make sense for to be
allergic to citric acid because you you
couldn't serve it's you nobody's
allergic to citric acid. Put it that
way. Okay. However, oranges and citrus
fruits because they're histamine content
can trigger allergic reactions. Ascorbic
acid is a completely different different
molecule than citric acid.
>> All right. Thank you so much for that.
And we have so many questions, Ben, that
I want to schedule some time really soon
where we go through all these questions
because I've copied them and we do
shorts with the answers.
>> Yeah, we can do one. We can do one
question at a time. We'll do like a a
two minute
>> one question. Yes, one question at a
time
>> and we are going to make that happen for
all of you folks because we are here to
serve. We are here to make sure that you
get the answers to your questions so
that you have more tools in your toolbox
to make those decisions that need to be
made when it comes to you being your own
health authority.
>> Love it. Love it.
>> Hey, hang on. I got to say one more
thing here.
>> Shout out Shout out to the guy who's
who's responsible for us all being here.
Dr. Wallak. I'm looking right at you.
>> Dr. Wallak.
>> Dr. Wallak. Shout out to Dr. Wallak.
Thank you for being on the call. Great
to see you and thank you for this is
your family here. We're all your family.
You're you're a grandpa or pod. Thank
you so much for everything you're doing.
Appreciate it.
>> Yes. So, I'm gonna go ahead and put put
him up here on the screen so that we can
give him a due.
Thank you, Dr. Wallik. I don't know. Let
me get you. Let me There you go. So, you
want to do a quick little message and
hello, Dr. Wallik, before we say
goodbye.
>> Okay. Well, yeah. I'll throw in a hello
and love everybody. Thank you for Mrs.
Ben for doing a great great great
service. Thank you Becca for doing a
great service. And it's one of those
things where we have this flip chart
which goes into everything you just
talked about. Okay, this flip chart.
Everybody should have this whether
they're going to build a long divvity
business or not because it'll add 25 to
50 healthful years. the information will
add 25 to 50 healthy years to them and
their families and their friends and
associates. So, thank you so much,
Pharmacist Ben. You did a great job.
>> Thank you, Doc. I appreciate you very
much. Thank you so much.
>> Someday,
>> someday I want to tell the story how I
met Doc. We have to do that on another
call. It's a great story.
>> Yes.
>> All right, you guys.
>> All right.
>> Well, thank you, Ben. Thank you, Doc.
And if I could get my co-hosts on the
screen with me, I just want to give them
a thank you also because I could not do
this without them, especially with all
the questions that are coming in and
people coming into the room. We want to
make sure that we keep this as a safe
place. We want people to come in um
promptly so they're not hanging out in
the waiting room when the meeting is
going on. And also we want to make sure
that we are getting this message out to
all the different platforms. And you
know folks sometimes as you're listening
to a program things go so quickly and
it's like what did they just say? Well,
we've got Marilyn to thank while you're
here in the Zoom room because she has
the ability to hear type and it's almost
instant. Um, and so she puts that into
the chat so that we can use that as a
reference and it's just very helpful to
me because I'm able to refer back to
that chat and get the information I need
for the notes on the show. So, thank you
Marilyn. Thank you Albert from way down.
They say down under, but I don't know
that South Africa the tip of it is far
down under is down under, but he's still
he's far down under there, folks. We
want to thank Albert for being here um
as it is late in the day for him. Thank
you so much. We have Phyllis who is
helping to fill the questions and also
put information into the chat as well.
Phyllis has been with Young and Dr.
Wallik for over 27 years and Youngevity
has been in business for 27 years and
they started helping and believing in
Dr. Wallik's message before Youngevity
was Youngevity. And then I also have
with me my my production manager. Now we
have an executive production manager but
we have the assistant to the executive
the production manager who helps us make
this all happen. Um, and that is AJ. And
I don't want to leave out because AJ I
mean AJ has us on all these different
platforms, folks. And I couldn't keep it
straight by myself, but between the two
of us, we have some pretty awesome
brains that work together. So, thank
you, AJ. And then for the person that
started getting all of this going, oh,
there's two people. Jonty, our web
master. So, if you go to
dailywithdoc.com
and we've got the videos there, we've
got the store there, we've got um
articles there, information that teach
you how to take the products, what's the
difference between the different packs.
That's all because of Jonty. So, I want
to do a shout out to Jonty. And then we
have MZ, Michael Zerling, who got Duck
on um the radio with the Dead Doctors
Don't Radio, Don't Lie Radio, which
Phyllis was very instrumental. Her and
Andy in MZ has just put all of this kind
of um stuff together. And that includes
pharmacists, Ben in our line of amazing
support and upline. It's just folks, we
have such an amazing community and I'm
going to add you back in here real quick
then that if you have never spoken to
anybody about longevity and you just
want to be part of a community with a
product line that can be trusted because
it works and then have this amazing
support system
where we can help you and support you in
getting this information out to those
you know we are your team.
Now there's a lot of great teams within
this community and I want to thank all
of them because I just see several of
the names here of some of the great
coaches. But if you have not spoken to
anybody, we invite you to get in contact
with us. Go to dailywithdoc.com
and ask to be part of this team and what
you need to do in order to get involved.
Ben, anything you want to add to that?
>> No. Thank you so much for what you're
doing, Rebecca, Doc, Phyllis, AJ,
Albert, Marilyn, everybody on the call,
Dave Michaels. Is MZ on the call? You
see MZ?
>> Um, I didn't see MZ, but you know, you
never know when he's gonna be listening
in.
>> And yeah, Dave is here. Thank you, Dave.
>> So, we'll see everybody next week. Bye,
everybody.
>> All right. Bye, everybody. Have a
fantastic weekend. And until next time,
don't forget to share, subscribe, and be
part of a community to heal the world.
My name's Becca Dukes. Bye for now.
Down.